Tony tell us about your role with the
ftth Council Brian do way it works
within the council is it is broken up
into a number of different committees so
to have deployment and operations to
have a finance committee and to have the
policy and regulation committee and so
I'm an external advisor to to policy and
regulation committee and I advise them
on how policies developing how
legislation and regulation is developing
and I advise them what aspects they
should look at as fiber to dorm council
to try and accelerate fiber deployments
what's your view on the current
regulatory issue well I mean I think
it's very interesting we're in a really
kind of an important or out and
important crossroads at the moment
because we have I suppose the first
thing is we're reviewing the Digital
Agenda targets so we currently have
targets which are 30 mega written 100
megabit but we heard from Commissioner
Roger on the first day of the conference
and he's talking about a 1 gigabit or a
gigabit society by 2025 so I suppose
that's very important from the fiber to
Rome cancelled perspective but the thing
that I find very interesting is that
Commissioner rotting or is not talking
about simply one metric he's looking at
upload speed he's talking about latency
he's talking about reliability and I
think this really positive because
Network fiber networks aren't just about
speed they're also about a number of
other different characteristics which
you know and all of these things will
play into I take fiber favor fiber
deployments so this is really good news
yeah I think so but I suppose it's
important to remember that this isn't
just it's not the only metric that's
going on or not the only thing that's
going on the other thing that's
happening is we're having a full review
of the whole legislative framework and
II said I different kind of levers the
policymakers that regulators can pull in
order to accelerate or encourage
investments in fiber networks it deals
with a lot of other issues as well of
course but it's very important from the
fiber to the home console perspective so
where would you like to see us go down
that regulatory path of the next kind of
three to five years well I mean I
suppose from the policy and regulation
committee we have looked a lot at
success stories and of course we've
looked at New Zealand I mean it was very
interesting grey Mitchell was here from
crown holdings in New Zealand where they
separated an old dress but something he
highlighted as the most important aspect
was to identify clearly a fiber
objective and and i suppose what we have
seen closer to home are some great
examples of countries that have achieved
very extensive and rapid
fiber-to-the-home deployments notably
portugal spain and even France moving
very fast and what we've seen is that
all of those countries have set a clear
target to achieve fiber but the second
thing they've done is they've taken a
number of measures to enable those fiber
deployments so they have introduced
measures to allow sharing a passive
infrastructures to share in building
wiring and the third thing that they've
done so the first is set the target the
second is enable that role like to
achieve that target undeterred is to
incentivize or create an incentive to
make for operators to make the
investments and you know it's there I
suppose that the review of the
legislative framework will have the
biggest impact and what we've seen is
that you know virtual remedies have been
removed and enabling measures such as
access to passive infrastructure's have
been put in place and it's had great
success for its role died so we'd really
like to see it up being deployed more
extensively across Europe so it's going
exciting few years I think well I think
so yes okay thanks for talking thank you